c'est quoi le mérite ça me parait chelou
d'abord il ya au moins deux manières de
l'employé mérité quelque chose et avoir
du mérite mais des deux sont liés en
général on mérite quelque chose parce
qu'on a du mérite par exemple on
reconnaît généralement que la notion de
mérite s'applique difficilement aux
choses du hasard je ne mérite pas de
gagner au loto il n'y a pas de mérite à
remporter une autre y on ne dira pas non
plus qu un enfant surdoué mérite ses
capacités mentales appelons le pierre on
considérera que pierre est plus ou moins
nez avec ces dispositions
ce que j'aime bien dire pour résumer
c'est on n'est pas capable de faire ce
qu'on n'est pas capable de faire
donc tout ce qu'on fait c'est ce qu'on
est capable de faire quel mérite y aura
t-il à faire quelque chose comme est
capable de faire le premier truc comme
répond en général c'est parce qu'on
aurait pu choisir de le faire
sous-entendu on jugera le mérite de
pierre adultes en fonction de
l'exploitation qui leur a fait de ses
capacités intellectuelles ceux qui
seraient déterminants pour le mérite ce
serait par exemple pour pierre d'avoir
su résister à la tentation du confort à
l'envi de se reposer sur ses compétences
sans en tirer le maximum
le mérite résidera dans l'effort ça en
fait une valeur morale généralement
associées au travail et ça ça pose
d'énormes difficultés
je sais bien qu'on a l'intuition forte
d'avoir un potentiel c'est-à-dire quand
même sentiment qu'on pourrait faire plus
si on décide et il ya des moments où
pierre joue aux jeux vidéo alors qu'il
pourrait réviser lire entretenir ses
capacités intellectuelles
il sent qu'ils pourraient se mettre à
travailler mais qu'il se laisse aller à
se divertir et donc ils culpabilisent
cette intuition est forte mais pas hyper
solide puisque en fait nous ne parlons
plus de ses capacités intellectuelles
mais bien de sa capacité à décider de se
mettre au boulot
pire est peut-être à nez avec des
facilités intellectuelles extraordinaire
mais il est peut être également née avec
de grosses difficultés de concentration
peut-être qu'il se fatigue très vite on
a donc affaire à une régression à
l'infini si le mérite n'est pas dû à sa
capacité de résoudre des problèmes
mathématiques de haut niveau mais au
fait d'avoir eu le courage de décider de
se mettre au boulot
sur les dix problème alors cela suppose
que les mérites repose sur l'ensemble
des dispositions qui permettent à pierre
de décider de travailler que ce soit le
courage l'autodiscipline l'ambition peu
importe mais mérite t'il d'avoir ces
dispositions
spontanément on associe de mérite à la
volonté il
je crois aussi à la facilité mais il a
choisi de poser d'arrache-pied mérite
son succès mais c'est une énorme
simplification on fait comme si la
volonté la détermination l'énergie comme
si tout ça ne renvoyez pas des capacités
qui sont cultivés par ailleurs d'où
vient la volonté de pierre qu'elle
partira l'héritage génétique à la petite
enfance à d'éducation il faudrait être
particulièrement de mauvaise foi pour ne
pas reconnaître que l'exploitation de
nos capacités tient énormément au monde
dans lequel on évolue
des parents disponibles des prof
attentif une bonne santé la confiance en
soi permise par un environnement
sécurisant tout cela sera forcément
déterminant dans le développement de la
volonté ou de la capacité de travail en
général pierre avait donc des capacités
mentales et un environnement qui a
favorisé chez lui la capacité de vouloir
travailler et la capacité de se mettre
des coups de pied au cul par moment où
est le mérite et dernier point quand
bien même serait ton responsable de
l'exploitation de notamment quand bien
même il y aurait un mérite à avoir
travaillé son potentiel
nous ne sommes pas responsables de ce
que la société décide de valoriser
pierre n'y peut rien si ses capacités
hors normes de calcul sont extrêmement
valoriser dans un monde d'informatique
et de finance et félix n'y peut rien si
dans ce même monde
son extrême sensibilité littéraire et
linguistique ne lui offre aucun statut
social particulièrement privilégiés en
conclusion le mérite morale est une
fiction tout ce dont ont joui c'est
grâce à la chance rendez votre argent
gagné par chance à ceux qui ne l'ont pas
eu